you know he was a man of great integrity
he was a statesman
of course that was part of his public
figure but he was also a family man
dedicated to his family and i think that
extended to his family in the army
certainly
his many years there rising to the
highest levels and at the state
department uh he cared about his troops
the career people at the state
department he did more uh in his four
years than had been done for so many
years to bring us up to date with new
technology he was a humble guy in his
own way
didn't expect
lots of great shows of
his exalted status although he was proud
to for instance to have been given an
honorary knighthood by her majesty the
queen after the first gulf war that was
something that was clearly important to
him when we were coming to london he
would say you know there i'm sir colin
and uh
he did that with a twinkle in his eye
he'll be remembered by many of course
for that speech he gave at the un where
he asserted that saddam hussein
did have weapons of mass destruction you
were working with him during that
difficult period
how much did that weigh on him do you
think through his later years that
period he took everything you know very
seriously but he also understood
uh the importance of moving on
look this is a man
who reached the highest levels of the
u.s military was the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff was the national
security adviser and then the secretary
of state
and many said of course that
he could have been president
that's a path he chose not to take
but i will always remember him as as the
ultimate diplomat in in many ways a rock
star
uh as we traveled around the world or
certainly even at home is there one
anecdote you could tell that kind of
that sums up the man do you think
something something that the story about
colin powell the man that sticks in your
memory well you know
he used to try to uh sort of ditch his
security detail within the state
department building and he would get in
the elevator and head to the basement or
the garage and talk to the guys down
there who parked the cars because that's
where he felt he could get the real
story of what was going on how was their
day going how did they see things uh and
i think that's what colin powell
understood that the sum of this
organization was every element that was
uh was a part of it was he more
comfortable in that company do you think
i think he dined with kings uh but he
also could enjoy a beer or just a chat
with anybody on the street that was
colin powell